good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Sam Anthony and I am the
director of the author lecture program
here on behalf of the archivist of the
United States I'd like to welcome you to
the National Archives and Records
Administration we're honored today to
have with us dr. Alan Weinstein as he
will discuss his book the Haunted wood
the Soviet espionage in America the
Stalin era a few points before we begin
copies of the book will be for sale
outside in the hallway following today's
lecture dr. Weinstein will be signing
copies of his book if we have time I
believe we will following his lecture we
will have a question-and-answer session
with the audience if you would like to
have our calendar of events mailed to
your home there is a sign-up fee also
outside where books are being sold we do
still have some free calendars for June
also the entrance of the theater well
why don't we get started
historian Alan Weinstein is founder
president and CEO of the Center for
democracy a nonprofit foundation created
in 1985 to promote and strengthen the
democratic process it's based in
Washington DC his international awards
include the United Nations peace medal
for efforts to promote peace dialogue
and free elections in several critical
parts of the world the Council of
Europe's silver medal twice in 1990 and
96 presented by its parliamentary
assembly for outstanding assistance and
guidance over many years he was a
university professor and professor of
history at Boston University from 1985
to 1989 and he was University professor
at Georgetown from 1981 to 1984 from
1966 to 1981 he was professor of history
at Smith College and chairman of its
American Studies program professor
Weinstein's book include the Haunted
wood the his chambers case which
received several citations including the
American Book Award nomination freedom
from crisis of freedom and crisis and
American history
between the wars American foreign policy
from Versailles to Pearl Harbor and
prelude to populism origins of the
silver issue would you please welcome
and Weinstein Thank You mr. Anthony I
would just make one slight correction
the title of the his chambers book is
perjury that his chambers case I want to
thank the National Archives for inviting
me to speak today the latest in a series
of programs here in which I've had the
good fortune to be involved over the
years I don't want to thank all of you
for coming today especially since the
book I will be discussing for a portion
of this hour is not hot off the press
but rather recently published in its
paperback edition by modern library so
much of what I have to say may already
be known to some of you the timing of
this talk about a book on Soviet
espionage in the United States however
has something to be said for itself a
former KGB officer now rules Russia by
popular election the President of the
United States today or tomorrow is in
route to Moscow to spend a weekend with
the Russian president and those who
opened your Washington Post this morning
found a lead editorial on US policy
toward Russia and a lead op-ed piece by
a distinguished Russian media executive
on threats to freedom of the media in
that country about all of which I will
have something to say before the hour is
over and finally I'll try to discipline
myself not to use the entire hour in my
prepared comments and to leave as much
time as possible for questions or for
all I know you're prepared comments
whatever that may be
how did one come to write a book on
Soviet espionage in the United States
during this period I could take a whole
hour with the description of that but
the the simplified version is that in
1993 my publisher Random House came to
an agreement with the Russian Foreign
Intelligence Service which was then
headed by Afghani Primakov who went on
to become foreign minister and briefly
Prime Minister of Russia and purchased
rights to access for several books to be
done jointly by Western historians and
and Russian Russians and in the case of
my co-author he's a he is a former agent
of the KGB who became a journalist
Alexander Vasily of now why did the KGB
or the former KGB folks sell access to
an up to at least some access to their
archives to an American publisher I
think most of you are familiar with the
famous Willie Sutton line about robbing
banks because that's where the money is
and they needed the money very badly at
that time but it turned into an
extremely interesting two-year research
experience in Moscow until those
archives were again closed it involved a
number of meetings with mr. Prem akov
and with various Soviet agents of an
earlier period about which we can talk
later perhaps first question why the
title the phrase the Haunted wood comes
from a well-known poem by WH Auden
September 1 1939 in which the relevant
lines are these all the conventions
conspire to make this fort assume the
furniture of home lest we should see
where we are lost in a haunted wood
children afraid of the Knights who have
never been happy or good
I used the title for this book because
it seemed to encapsulate the moral
confusions of many Americans who fueled
by romantic anti-fascist and
pro-communist convictions became spies
for the Soviet Union believing in a
number of cases that they were not
necessarily betraying their own country
in doing so this issue has this issue of
Soviet espionage has in recent months
again fuelled a certain amount of public
debate some of you familiar with a long
article by jason jacob weisberg in a
late november 99 issue of the new york
times magazine under the heading the
rehabilitation of joe mccarthy in which
he describes a continuing debate among
scholars over the nature and meaning of
soviet espionage in america during the
Depression and World War two and this
article I'll I'll refer to some of the
issues raised in this article recent
studies by historians often based on
previously secret US and Soviet
intelligence files have rekindled debate
in short over interpreting that those
issues at a similar moment in a life of
Soviet scholarship at
decade ago at a meeting in Moscow of
Russian and American Historians which in
which I chaired the US side this was
before the collapse of the Soviet Union
one young russian scholar whispered to
me about the manner in which his
colleagues were confronting new Western
scholarship which shattered their
earlier Cold War shibboleths you know I
live in a remarkable country Alan we can
predict the future and understand the
present perfectly but the past the past
keeps changing every day the end of the
Cold War has brought a significant
measure of new evidence and
reconsideration to the subject I want to
cover today so let me begin with some
comments not only about my own book but
about this new history of Soviet
espionage that as it has been called the
sweet
spy fiction always floods the literary
marketplace but in the past year spy
fact has raced to catch up specifically
our basic understanding of Cold War
espionage in the United States and
England has deepened with publication
over the year year and a half just
passed of four overlapping books each
filling in a significant aspect of the
research landscape their co-authors
include three Americans three Russians
and two Englishmen the latest of these
the sword and the shield written by
Cambridge historian Christopher Andrew
and former KGB archivist Vasily Metropia
through a major news stories with
details about yet another Soviet agent
working on atomic energy matters during
World War two in this case an 87 year
old English woman who promptly
acknowledged her involvement in the
process Andrew was a prolific scholar of
modern intelligence best known for a
previous book on KGB history written
with an earlier defector Oleg Gordievsky
and he used in this current volume
several thousand items copied over the
years from the KGB archives by mr. Matt
Rogan before his retirement in 1984
material which he brought to England
where he sought asylum
another previously secret cache of
documents this one from American
intelligence sources was used skillfully
in John Earl Haynes and Harvey Claire's
book Venona decoding Soviet espionage in
America as well as in the Weinstein
Vassiliou book Claire and Haynes
identified over 300 Soviet agents in
sources in the United States during the
1930s and 40s
using the deciphered transcriptions of
World War 2 Soviet intelligence cables
assigned at the time the project named
Venona whose documents were released
finally by the CIA and the NSA in 1995
and 96 a third study published here last
March by espionage expert Nigel West and
another former KGB official Oleg serif
called the crown jewels of the British
secrets at the heart of the KGB archives
was mainly focused on Soviet spying in
England but it did contain valuable
material on such a agents as the atomic
spy Klaus Fuchs who also operated in the
United States and finally the Haunted
wood Soviet espionage in America the
Stalin era which I wrote with mr.
phacelia who like Metropia now lives in
England used extensively both Venona
files and for the first time an array of
KGB files on Soviet espionage in the
United States requested by the authors
from it from the cave only former KGB
Moscow archives now what have we learned
from all four books each based on
previously unavailable materials in the
case of Americans who provided
information and documents to Soviet
operatives during the 1930s and more
years they confirm with new evidence the
involvement of such figures as Alger
Hiss Harry Dexter white Gerald Browder
Julius Rosenberg Lachlan Currie White
House aide Lachlan curry I might add
Lawrence Duggan theater Hall yet another
atomic spy and hundreds of others
according to the Haynes clear itemized
count and so we can now say with some
assurance that Soviet spy networks were
active throughout the US government
during these years at the State
Department the Treasury the War
Department among other agencies at the
supposedly top-secret Office of
Strategic Services the OSS predecessor
to the CIA and at the super-secret
Manhattan Project then developing the
atomic bomb although at most hundreds of
the tens of thousands of open Communist
Party members cooperated with Soviet
agents their efforts were aided abetted
and led by the party's leader Earl
Browder until he was unceremoniously
dropped for membership in a post-war
purge at Stalin's direct instructions
other new evidence disputes the
allegation made by a previous book
that's that the great scientist J robert
Oppenheimer assisted Soviet intelligence
nor does Ethel Rosenberg executed along
with her husband in 1953 for supposed
involvement in atomic espionage emerged
from the Venona and the KGB files as
more than a witting supportive wife but
probably not deeply involved or may in a
major way in Julius's covert efforts the
KGB files also document the link to
Soviet operatives of a u.s. congressman
a Hollywood producer the daughter of the
US ambassador to Nazi Germany and other
well-known figures it's a book filled
with love affairs actual or plotted
murders agent business ventures
defections many other dramatic episodes
I won't go into them all except to
suggest that to the best of my knowledge
the only two figures I could find who
actually worked for money for the
Soviets as opposed to ideological
conviction alone or a Hollywood producer
and a u.s. congressman I leave you to
draw your own conclusions from that in
short there was an extensive effort to
recruit Americans for espionage it
depended heavily on romantic
anti-fascist and pro-communist
ideologues during the pre-war and world
war ii periods but basically in the in
the Cold War era that effort shifted to
recruitment for money and because of
personal grievances as Christopher
Andrew and other studies demonstrate but
did Stalin and his few cohorts in top
Soviet leadership use much of the
valuable intelligence gained by the
efforts of the KGB and military
intelligence operatives in the US and
Great Britain the clearest case of
crucial and immediate use involves
transmission of data from the Manhattan
Project obtained through the efforts of
Julius Rosenberg David Greenglass Klaus
Fuchs theater Hall Harry gold and others
although only the full release of Soviet
archives can tell a complete story
existing scholarship to stone that shown
that the transfer of scientific and
technical data from Western laboratories
undoubtedly saved the Soviets several
years in developing their own atomic
weapons
was it unimportant for the Soviet Union
to have highly placed agents such as
algae hiss Kim Philby Harry Dexter white
Donald MacLean and Lachlan curry
transmitting up-to-date news of
decisions from top US and British
policymakers directly to Moscow however
we are not likely to increase soon our
precise unjust awareness of what use
Stalin and others in the Kremlin made of
such information since the kg our KGB
archives have been shut tight again one
reviewer of my book even argued that by
and large quoting him Moscow gleaned
more or more value from its open wartime
alliance with Washington than by its
secret underground rings but the
evidence to date in these four volumes
alone can make a credible case for a
major harm inflicted by Moscow's agents
for example if it were discovered today
that among those providing classified
information to a foreign government
where a top presidential aide leading
officials at state defense and the CIA
and a member of Congress among others I
think few Americans would question the
significance of such espionage nor was
national security less jeopardized by
those Americans who worked for pay
during the Cold War even if in more
modest posts the smih trojans documents
helped lead in 1996 to the arrest and
conviction of robert littke who assisted
the soviets as a code clerk for the
National Security Agency thirty years
earlier during the 1960s and who had his
sentencing three decades later for
having betrayed his country exclaimed I
feel like Rip Van spy one decisive
conclusion emerges dramatically from
several of these books my own included
throughout the 30s and 40s the US and
British governments learn far more about
Soviet espionage in their countries from
the revelations of defectors than from
their own inadequate counterintelligence
expert efforts at Soviet code clerk Igor
Gouzenko not defected to Canada in 1945
and that same year Elizabeth Bentley not
changed her role from Soviet courier to
FBI informant reinforcing Whittaker
Chambers earlier statements to the
bureau of out communist espionage we
would never have gained an early if
still partial understanding of Soviet
spy rings in North America later Soviet
our
who defected to the West during the Cold
War decades among them Oleg Gordievsky
and now Igor Metropia
also brought with them invaluable
material and memories to flesh out the
story of their services efforts and
accomplishments in Western Europe and
the United States in Moscow my own
conversations with leading officials of
the Russian Foreign Intelligence Agency
which is the successor agency to the
Foreign Intelligence work of the KGB
confirmed in the 90s both they're still
fierce anger at mr. Gordievsky in
particular and by implication the
accuracy of the river of the
recollections he sat down in his book
with Christopher Andrew
despite periodic counterintelligence
successes during the Cold War decades
for once the the belated identification
and arrest of Aldrich Ames the CIA is
now recognized Mull despite this and the
recent flurry of charges and
counter-charges related to alleged
Chinese espionage at Los Alamos there is
I think a continuing problem confronted
by US counterintelligence in the post
Cold War period
absent reliable testimony by those who
have renounced the other side of
whatever country for our own side the
questions that remain to be answered
concerning Soviet espionage in the
United States and elsewhere in other
words continue to overwhelm even the new
evidence produced up-to-date by all of
these books my own included which
suggests that those of us responsible
for these four books and four other
recent studies of Russian espionage
might be advised to retain an
appropriate modesty about the
conclusiveness of our still earlier are
still very early probes into the
dramatis persona the activities and the
significance of Soviet espionage now let
me confront directly if briefly one
question often asked of about my book in
these others what impact has the new
research on Soviet espionage had on our
understanding of McCarthyism and
specifically does it justify what the
the person who wrote The Times magazine
headline called its rehabilitation
so-called the answer is absolutely not
because among other factors my own
research and that of other recent
scholars on the subject show that the
Soviet spy networks
closed down in the United States by 1946
right after the defection of major agent
and courier Elizabeth Bentley who named
names thus by the time McCarthy began
his effort four years later there were
virtually no Soviet agents in the United
States to be found and we're not for
some time after that the poet Marion
Moore once described the writing of
poetry as the creation of imaginary
gardens with real toads in them now
there that has a relevance to espionage
because in effect Senator McCarthy in
some of his investigative colleagues on
the hill created a variety of imaginary
gardens of espionage yes there were real
toads I've just named some of them yes
they were figures who betrayed their
country are there were serious internal
security issues but these are in any
period our own as well far too important
to be left to the zealots and the
ideologue another question is whether
the those who would still defend
American communism during that period
accept the reality that at least some
members of the Communist Party in this
earlier generation can work the Soviet
espionage agents or do they continue to
live in denial well the best answer I
can have is to ask them yourself but
from what has been published to date
some recent defenders of the Rosenbergs
innocence for example have can now
conceded that Julius at least was an
active agent although it is hard to find
anyone today certainly not your speaker
who defends the couple's execution for
whatever crimes they might have
committed others on the left like one
scholar quoted by mr. Weisberg in The
Times concede widespread espionage by
communists in the 1930s and 40s but
defend the practice on the grounds that
these people spied purportedly and I'm
quoting here not because they were
traitors but because they did not
subscribe to traditional forms of
patriotism this apologia for atomic
espionage plumbs white what might best
be described as the lower depths of the
higher law now as serious Americans at
the beginning of what may be a century
at least as internationally dangerous as
the one just
if in different ways and with different
adversaries can we wrap around our minds
around the notion that there exist real
internal security issues but do so
without succumbing to demagogic hysteria
about them can we deal in short and
present and future with our real toads
without constructing new imaginary
gardens and my answer is why not if we
at least learned appropriately some of
the lessons I'm discussing here a1
admitted major atomic spy and I stress
admitted atomic spy for the Soviets
Klaus Fuchs
once described the psyche of an
espionage agent as involving controlled
schizophrenia which might be a useful
concept for Americans to ponder in
thinking about how best to confront in
our own time those who betray the values
of our democratic society but in a
manner which assures that we do not
betray those values ourselves now I'm
often asked and it's a nagging question
for me as well about motivation why did
these folks spy of course the the
mixture of motives will depend upon the
individual involved but most of
themselves pointed to their anti-fascist
convictions their communist or
pro-communist orientations as decisive
reasons ideological reasons in short in
the 1930s and 40s but I want to share
with you a brief passage from one of the
finest explorations of this question
that I know of it comes from the
novelist John Banville 1997 book the
untouchable which some of you may have
read based on the career of the British
art historian and key Soviet agent
Anthony Blunt the so called fourth man
or fifth man depending on how you count
who worked with Philby Burgess MacLean
and Karen cross the so called Cambridge
which ring of spies this is mr. bet mr.
band Vil talking through the mind of his
blunt figure whom he named Victor Masco
in the novel perhaps it was not
philosophy by which I live but the
double life itself which at first seemed
to so many of us a source of strength
that acted upon me as a debilitating
force I know this has always been said
of us that the lying and the secrecy
inevitably corrupted us sapped our moral
strength and blinded us to the actual
nature of things but I never believed it
could
be true we were latter Diagnostics
keepers of a secret knowledge for whom
the world of appearances was only a
gross manifestation of an infinitely
subtler more real reality known only to
the chosen few but the iron electable
laws of whichever everywhere at work
this gnosis was on the material level
the equivalent of the Freudian
conception of the unconscious that
unacknowledged an irresistible
legislator that spy in the heart thus
for us everything was itself and at the
same time something else so we could rag
about the place and drink all night and
laugh ourselves silly because beyond all
of our frivolity there operated the
stern conviction that the world must be
changed and that we were the ones who
would do it at our lightest we seemed to
ourselves possessed of the seriousness
far more deep partly because it was
hidden than anything our parents could
manage with their vagueness ease and
lack of any certainty Andy rigor above
all their contemptibly feeble efforts at
being good let the whole sham fortress
fall we said and if we can give it a
good hard shove we will it was all
selfishness of course we did not care a
damn about the world much as we might
shout about freedom and justice and the
plight of the masses all selfishness the
fact is the majority of us had no more
than the sketchiest grasp of theory we
did not bother to read the text we had
others to do that for us the working
class comrades were the great readers
communism could not have survived
without autodidact I knew one or two of
the shorted pieces the manifesto of
course that great ringing shout of
wishful thinking and had made a
determined start on capital the dropping
of the definite article was de rigueur
for a smart young men so long as the
pronunciation was f Dutch but soon got
bored politics anyway was not books
politics was action I'll leave you with
that little passage from van de ville
and move on to my next subject as I
indicated in my opening comments I want
to address in my remaining time some
broader issues removed from the
espionage subject of this talk I hope
that is acceptable to you specifically
the question of what the United States
has done and can still do to further the
complex progress of democracy and the
rule of law in what had been KGB's
country and now one hopefully is no
longer
the post KGB country in the Russian
Federation the small non-governmental
Center which I helped to found and still
had sixteen years later has been deeply
involved in a range of efforts and
programs related to the transformation
in Russia so this is much on my
professional mind as well other and my
own control schizophrenia half of my
life is spent running the center and the
other half writing history and one tries
to keep those in their proper
compartments but I've traveled to Russia
some 50 or 60 times in the past decade
and and have a few thoughts on that
subject it seems a fair statement
thinking of the Russian Federation alone
in December 1991 which after a
millennium of tyrannical rule suddenly
found itself having dispensed with its
Soviet constraints it seems a fair
statement that never in human history
has a nation been asked simultaneously
and with neither historical precedent
nor preparation to reconstruct
simultaneously again I remind you it's
political structure its governmental
system its economic system its legal
system its underlying approach to ethics
its relationships with the world as
occurred in Russia at that moment and
continues to occur to the present all
changed
as the poet Yates wrote about a far less
complicated situation in Ireland in 1916
all changed changed utterly but terrible
beauty is born applicable I think to
Russia from 1991 onward virtually
overnight there was some forewarning
because of the collapse of the Soviet
Union's Eastern European Empire in the
preceding two years the Cold War gave
way to the post Cold War era
abruptly for American policymakers and
the public the gracious familiarly
genial Soviet leadership style of
Mikhail Gorbachev gave way to the
unfamiliar and unpredictable Russian
Cadence's of Boris Nikolayevich Yeltsin
and his colleagues laying before us a
suddenly pro-western menu of policies
and actions and this change was neither
easy nor initially comfortable for the
Bush administration and obviously it was
not for Gorbachev and his colleagues I
happened to be in Moscow
the day before this happened on one of
my visits and had lunch at the foreign
ministry with the then deputy foreign
minister who urged me to persuade my
friends in the Yeltsin camp to let the
Soviet Union die a more leisurely death
over the next several years as best for
the country it was odd to be an American
messenger of this but it turned out that
evening a dinner for those of you who
read David rednecks book if heard the
story already I was having dinner with
my friend Andre kasra with a foreign
minister then of the Russian Federation
and who already knew about this effort -
- on the part of people to persuade
President Yeltsin not to move quickly
but rather than respond to my comments
about my luncheon meeting he flipped out
a notebook and turned to me and said
over dinner tell me professor tell me
the difference between a Commonwealth
and Association and a confederation and
as you know the following day in Minsk
President Yeltsin and his colleagues
from Ukraine and Belarus created the
so-called Commonwealth of Independent
States and declared the Soviet Union at
an end it was a very odd experience to
boot and I think one that for many
Russians remains complex in terms of
their loyalties and their sense of what
they want this new country to be we
certainly could not have predicted it
and from almost the moment that the the
new new realities took shape however we
attempted as best we could to at least
be generous and supportive the United
States and Western Europe responded
generously during those earlier years of
the 1990s with emergency aid with food
with medicines with basic supplies with
emergency loans but none of the Western
democracies ourselves included took a
lead in organizing in cooperation with
the Yeltsin government a coherent plan
for initiating and implementing the
staggering process of transforming that
command economy into serious market
structures capable of managing
large-scale privatization or of creating
a post communist class of genuine
entrepreneurs and managers perhaps that
was too much to expect I'm not going to
review all the complications that both
the bush and the clinton administration
have faced in this process i would
suggest however that whatever
there have been achievements here but
whatever mistakes of omission or
Commission have been committed in our
policies toward Russia from 1991 to the
present by both administrations that it
may be helpful it will be helpful if the
if the those in charge of US policy
today I think they can do their
successors a great final service by
producing in the closing months of this
administration for use by either
President Gore or President Bush whoever
becomes president a comprehensive white
paper outlining what was done in detail
what seemed useful and in retrospect
what neither worked nor was helpful and
what guidelines for a new bipartisan
policy toward Russia they might commend
to their successors and I stressed
bipartisan and I'll come back to that
point now we don't have time in the few
minutes remaining to me for to do a
program by program assessment of this
process and of the difficulties faced in
the 1990s of providing serious
assistance to to the Russian government
and the Russian people but I think it's
important to remember that neither
Presidents Bush nor Clinton had received
from the American electorate in there
either in 1988 or 1992 or 96 nor for
that matter had they requested a mandate
to engage in long term extensive and
sustained assistance to the Russian
government of the sort that presidents
Truman Eisenhower Kennedy Johnson and
Nixon had received in supporting
economic aid programs related to US
national security during the Cold War
era beginning of course with our
greek-turkish aid program in the
Marshall Plan and continuing through
point-four and other programs in fact
it's important to remember that the 1992
and 96 elections might arguably be
called our first presidential contest
since 1936 which were fought without an
overriding foreign policy question
involved so that it is probably fair to
say that the United States and other
Western countries were simply or have
been simply unprepared in their
electorates intellectually and
financially for the challenges of the
post communist Russia and to some extent
we remain unprepared today however in
the eight years that follow
the collapse of the Soviet Union there
have been an extraordinary range of
intergovernmental governmental and
private assistance programs related to
encouraging the development of
democratic institutions civil society
and the rule of law in Russia today and
these programs the number of them have
been extraordinarily helpful the the
flaws in the programs were outlined or
some of the programs in a very pointed
and impressive article by George Soros
who's contributed significantly funding
to number of these programs in a recent
article in The New York Review of Books
that some of you may have read in
another another forum but we don't have
time to review the problems and the like
what might be more useful in my few
remaining moments is first of all to
stipulate a tribute to all of those
Friends of Russia abroad whether
governmental or non-governmental who
have struggled to support the
monumentally difficult range of problems
confronting their nascent
democratization country problems ranging
from the imbalance of power among the
branches of the Russian national
government the presidents too powerful
the Legislature's too deferential the
judicial branch is not fully effective
yet to the unresolved contest over
authority that we're witnessing in the
media today as we read about a day by
day between the central government and
the the governors of the different
provinces to the Russian government's
often hostile relationship toward free
and unfettered media as in the case of
the police raid on the major independent
television network NTV recently which
one hopes will not be repeated toward
the indifference of government toward
independent non-governmental
organisations my environmentalist
friends found that the state Committee
on Environmental Protection was simply
abolished by the new by the end by
President Putin of about a week ago you
may have seen the story in the
newspapers there are many many problems
of this kind of you well one is well
aware I'm well aware and I think all of
us are with the half empty nature of the
Russian democratization glass today
however just as many of us myself
included were undoubtedly too optimistic
a decade ago about the pace of
democratization in Russia after the
collapse of Soviet of the Soviet Union
are we not perhaps to a shade too
pessimistic about that process
today because I think most Russians
would concede that there will be no
going back to any communist Russia and
there have been a number of successes in
a variety of areas that we can talk
about later if you'd like but I do have
some suggestions for future support for
that country that I want to outline
briefly before concluding and taking
questions first of all it would be
helpful I think in future if we thought
of assistance to Russia as multilateral
not unilateral one of the saddest is
little-noticed
elements in limiting the impact of
foreign assistance on Russian
democratization programs the ones that
I'm particularly concerned with has been
the uncoordinated and unilateral nature
of much of this aid at the governmental
and intergovernmental levels in brief
agencies of the US government have
supported our programs USAID and others
the European Union have supported its
programs the German government its
programs and so forth more often than
not not only was there no coordination
of these overlapping programs but there
was not even cooperation and in many
instances not even communication amongst
Americans and Europeans working the same
terrain in Russia and I don't accept our
nongovernmental organizations from this
this same process and if nothing else we
certainly can provide four ways using
the computer of keeping one another
informed on what each of us is doing and
seeing if we can indeed cooperate with
one another in future and maximize the
impact of our assistance secondly
increase the human exchanges this is a
no-brainer
and one whose importance cannot be
overestimated exchange programs that
have brought thousands and are now
bringing tens of thousands of Russians
from throughout the country from
throughout the range of professions to
democratic societies to observe the
operations of such societies in Europe
in the United States even in Asia
these are arguably the most cost
effective instruments for educating that
country citizens in the economic and
political potential of a democratic
Russia they deserve all the governmental
and private support possible support for
media during an election monitoring
visit to Russia on my part part of the
center for democracy election monitoring
group several weeks ago one of my oldest
friends there
now a media executive formally in the
Elson government argued that the best
service the United States government and
society could perform for Russian
democracy today is to make it plain in
the strongest terms to Russia's new
leaders including its president what
type of behavior the Community of
Democracies found acceptable and which
actions crossed the line nowhere more
urgently than in the pressures that
President Putin and his colleagues
apparently wish to exert on constraining
the freedom of the media both domestic
and foreign in that country I think I've
said something about this already in
that connection I would add also
supporting the freedom of
nongovernmental organizations whether
environmental or human rights or or
legal organizations to pursue their
efforts hopefully with government
support but certainly without government
opposition we have to also begin leaving
Moscow and st. Petersburg and the other
major cities to do more of what we want
to do in the regions of Russia the bulk
of foreign support for Russia
economically as well as on
democratization has been concentrated
inevitably in the cities and the major
cities and in the in the period ahead I
think all of us who are involved in this
effort agree that more of this support
should go into the regions increasing
rule of law cooperation with Russia's
judicial branch is absolutely critical
and I can go into detail later but I'm
running out of time if we're going to
have time for questions so I won't go
into those measures but for example the
Russian supreme and supreme arbitration
courts that is to say their major
commercial court the key leaders of this
are creating a Russian judicial academy
comparable to those judicial academies
in Western countries and we ought to
support this to the fullest with the
resources that will help train the
judges and train the lawyers in Russia
in a way that brings them into
coordination with the broader European
and global legal standards of
organizations such as the Council of
Europe the European Court of Human
Rights and the European Union the US
government is really take is really in
the back seat here because Russia is
after all European country but we should
help in every way we can bring the
politicians here there's they're
wonderful programs going on the Library
of Congress has an excellent one now
bringing groups from the Russian Duma
and federal council here those should be
expanded and supported which brings me
perhaps to my
final two points in this regard I think
it's critical when the president returns
I some of us would have preferred that a
bipartisan delegation from Congress
accompany him but when he returns that
we really addressed the task of
restoring a bipartisan consensus on
American policy toward Russia under the
Putin government I think the lead here
has to be taken by the leaders of
Congress the Republican leadership of
Congress and by President Clinton and
one hopes when he returns that there
will be an effort to assure that whoever
becomes president this year that
bipartisanship returns as a fundamental
element in our in our policy toward
Russia I say that not only because I had
a lead a bipartisan center with our
directors coming from both parties but
because it's absolutely critical so that
one party does not play another off one
on the other on who is responsible for
this and who is responsible for that
and finally it seems to me that we have
to recognize that we can only do so much
that the United States is not in fact in
a lead in a position to affect each and
every aspect of the internal
democratization process in Russia that
ultimately it is up to the Russian
people themselves as to what they will
put up with and what they would not I
always remind my Russian friends that if
they want to let a lesson in what the
limits are of being only 10 years out of
your independence moment check the
United States in 1786 and see what we
had done and what we had not done and
use that perhaps as a measurement for
what you've achieved and what you
haven't yet achieved and don't be too
just too demoralized by what remains to
accept to come I'll stop there accept
historians are always there are lessons
to be learned in this process of what
went right and what has gone wrong in
our relationship with Russia what's gone
right from my perspective is for several
years the among other things the KGB
archives were open to historians such as
myself and I managed to get a book out
of this which I'm proud of in which I
hope you will enjoy reading which is why
we're allegedly here today before I
started talking more generally about
Russia but historians were always
talking about lessons and the lessons
they've learned
I don't have the time to talk about some
of the ones I've learned but certainly
in connection with the rise and fall of
democracies one has to keep in mind that
one thing leads to another the law of
unintended unintended consequences is
always supreme but there's another one
and that's my favorite one in this
regard which is the law of surprises if
you'd been in Washington in nineteen in
a 1988 or 1989 and I it's and we've been
having this conversation and I said
ladies and gentlemen in two years within
two years the entire communist structure
and system in Central and Eastern Europe
will have collapsed unraveled the
Federal Republic of Germany will absorb
East Germany the other countries of the
Central Europe will become free and
independent again and there will be no
Soviet Union what would you have done
you know what you have done you would
have laughed at me you would have said
that's ridiculous and that's absurd but
the law we were in fact in the 1980s
still predicting that we would have to
deal with the communist system in this
room in a in in a Syria in a set of
intractable spheres I remember that
doctrine which came out of a State
Department figure who shall remain
nameless at this particular moment
well the intractable became the very
tractable and I suspect that can happen
again so there is room for optimism if
we will provide the kind of support that
our Russian friends need in the period
ahead and also make it clear what we
will not accept as from a fellow democra
from a state which purports to be a
fellow Democratic Society if we keep
those interests clear I think we should
have some very interesting times ahead
of us and not too bad as a period and
I'll stop there and take questions and I
thank you for attention
last year tony has the son of Alger Hiss
vote from the same podium right he
predicted that dumb when further former
Soviet archives are open that there may
be details that would alter the recent
revelations about his father's hates
Authority happy to some of you may
recall a gentleman named general Volcker
gun off who was approached by people
related to the defense of mr. hiss after
the changeover from the Soviet Union to
to Russia and general vote Pagano wasn't
working steadily in the archives that a
number of projects and he was asked to
see if there was any material there on
Alger Hiss he went to his friend then
director Primakov and he went into the
KGB archives which is the archive he was
asked to look at
although Whittaker Chambers had
indicated that Alger Hiss did not work
for the KGB he worked for Russian
military intelligence which is a quite
separate archive which has not been
opened he then wrote mr. hensel's
attorneys a letter saying that he found
nothing that indicated mr. his would
work for the Soviets they wished him
well used in the press ballyhooed and
the president might be said a great deal
as the quote exoneration unquote eval
tree his if you want a full account of
this check the last chapter of of the
new edition of perjury which is
published in paperback about a year and
a half a to ago general Volcker Ghana
was forced to retract that statement
when it was pointed out that he had not
made a thorough search of the or even
the KGB archives spent a day or two
there and that he had not looked at the
military archives where the his files
have originally been kept what what does
one say about release of the archives
when I was phoned by a reporter for The
New York Times asking what I felt about
general Vulcanus initial statement I
said very honestly what any historian
would say well that reopens the case I
began my research into this case under
the premise that mr. hiss was probably
innocent and changed my mind in the
course of doing my research and and
threw away a good portion of a book
already written because it
was not the book supported by the
evidence can historians change their
minds on this of course but what I found
in in the KGB archives were bits and
pieces and and there's some evidence in
Venona as well but in the KGB archives
that reinforced the involvement of mr.
his Stephen in the 1930s not they
weren't supposed to be there but he was
talking to agents of the kid who were
working for the kg with what was any of
the predecessor agency of the KGB and so
there were various citations to mr. hiss
that reinforced the case for his
involvement that can be found studded
throughout the new edition over the
addition of the Haunted wood and what
you may want to do if you haven't had a
chance to do it is to take a look at the
references to Alger Hiss and the Haunted
wood and see if they provide any insight
but as far as tony hisses statement
we're all we're all slaves of the future
well we have to wait to see what happens
but for the moment I've seen nothing to
change my initial analysis of the thing
except to believe so I was an agnostic
as to whether Alger Hiss had remained a
Soviet agent during the war when I first
wrote perjury in the 1970s based on the
new material I'm persuaded that he did
remain a Soviet agent right up to his
departure from the State Department for
exchange programs how do you how do you
square that with evidence that countries
like China have used that we are with
students and scientists working over
here as a major part of their espionage
efforts against the United States for
such things as technology transfer well
I think yeah it's squaring that it's not
a problem for me because for one thing
one don't we you don't have to take
exchange scholars or researchers into
the heart of your secret efforts in
order to have a decent exchange program
it has never been been the case possibly
although we don't always consider it as
such possibly the most successful
exchange program ever run in the history
of the world was the Fulbright Program
which brought to the United States over
a period of senators since it was
initiated after the Second World War
thousands upon thousands of
even hundreds of thousands of of people
from the range of countries around the
world which created in effect for the
most part groups of extremely
influential figures in virtually every
country in the world who understood
America they didn't have to agree with
us on everything our governments
policies but they were implicitly
understanding compassionate and
supportive of our efforts as a as a
democratic society in connection with
Russia that's having some of the same
effect and has over the past 10 years in
connection with China as you have
mentioned and I suppose you could
mention other countries in terms of
these exchanges of similar concerns
about the national security elements one
in effect can be cautious as to where
people go and be very careful as to what
they're not getting into but also keep
in mind what's happening in China today
keep in mind the dramatic pace of
personal change in China to keep in mind
what's happening as a result of the
computer the widespread use of computers
and the Internet and alike and and
economic activity there's one can almost
imagine this situation in China as a
kind of race to the future between
retrograde forces perhaps some of their
military perhaps some in in their
intelligence services in those worlds
and others in Chinese society including
a number of their leaders who see a
different kind of China I don't say they
see a Democratic China yet but we are
certainly over the next 10 or 20 years
going to see which of those societies
manages to which of which of those
leadership Tadros manages to to hold
sway in China and as to our interest to
assure that a leadership more committed
to an open China when open society has
whatever encouragement we can provide
them without being stupid about our own
national security as I said one of the
dilemmas we faced as a country is that
we I don't think we've ever had I don't
what I don't disagree with most people
in the intelligence community as far as
I read about them in the Washington Post
and elsewhere they seem to share the
notion that our count
counterintelligence efforts could be
beefed up so those should be beefed up
how do you see yourself that the
documents are being given to look at by
the Russians were authentic and were you
able to deal with them in rush
you rely on translators and interpreters
no as I said and as I said and in the
Haunted wood it's all very clear that
the deal made with the with the Russian
Foreign Intelligence Service that Random
House concluded said that Western
authors were not allowed into the
archives the Russian authors the Russian
authors dealt with the art they we could
make our request but the Russian authors
are the ones who dealt with it's all in
the introduction to the Haunted wood
which I commend to you but how do we
assure their authenticity well there are
a variety of ways well one of which is
the fact that I in fact looked at a
number of those documents with Russian
translator friends there I don't speak
Russian I don't read Russian but which
which is also in the introduction of the
Haunted wood but that in most instances
these documents had not been even opened
in in 20 30 or 40 years or since since
the time that they they had been
produced the Russians have a fascinating
system for that period they probably
changed it in the 1960s and 70s when
they began reading Western management
books or maybe I don't know maybe CIA
manuals or something but but but
documents were sewn together sewn
together so you'd open a folio this is
with string with cords hard string you'd
open a folio and there would be a report
from the Russian station chief in New
York on what he'd been doing her in
Washington next to a letter from a
communist steel worker giving $5 to
Comrade Stalin to be used in whatever
fashion he wanted to use it after which
there would be things that were
obviously irrelevant to the historian of
things that were quite relevant with a
sign up with a signing sheet as to who
had used this material from from from
the beginning what what nailed down for
not only my own book but for for several
the other books so the the the
authenticity issue was well first of all
the authenticity she was nailed down by
the book very sheer complexity of what
emerged no they didn't have a group of
people some of the material I got I got
only because my author left my co-author
left Russia under threat that's pretty
authentic to me when the archivist and
the archives say that once once was a
guy enough wins the election which they
did in 1996 you know we'll deal with you
and we'll deal with the others who
working with the Westerners now but but
when the Venona documents were released
and you found the same cable essentially
being transcribed deciphered and
transcribed by our intelligence people
in Washington as you found in Moscow I
notice in the footnotes to the Haunted
wood once I hope you have a chance to
look at it you'll notice there are about
50 or 60 citations in which I quote a
document taken from the Moscow archives
then I quote the American doctor the
same document as as emerging from Venona
and finally in exasperation my editor
said for God's sakes you know I wish the
company doesn't have the money to let
you to do all of this and so I just
stopped but I could done it for a number
of others as well but authenticity is
always a problem for the historian and
in this instance I think I persuaded
that there there are no problems here my
other thing is that it cost my
collaborator his his ability to live in
Russia it's pretty authentic to me there
was there's been stories that Martha got
when she was living in Berlin had
affairs perhaps intimate affairs the
number of American personalities who
were visiting Berlin at 1936 for the
Olympics including like the the American
writer Thomas book did you ever come
across anything in the documentation
about her her contacts with the Soviet
intelligence service of her trying to
attempt to turn any of these people well
short answer is no but let me tell rest
of the audience who were talking about
Delon was asking about a fascinating
woman I gather there's several books
coming out on her so to be able to know
much more about her soon named Martha
Dodd who was the daughter of ambassador
William Dodd the US ambassador to Nazi
Germany front end during the first
Roosevelt term 33 to 37 a fine historian
and a very close personal friend as as
his entire family was of Franklin and
Eleanor Roosevelt so that you ambassador
Dodd would write not through state but
he communicated quite often directly
to the White House into the president
Martha Dodd was young extremely bright
very restless very glamorous very
attractive and she immediately plunged
into German Berlin society at the time
and began a variety of love affairs one
of which was with a Soviet diplomat
named the no Greta
with whom she fell deeply in love and
agreed he was soon under the control of
Russian intelligence of Soviet
intelligence at the time she agreed to
become an agent which meant that she was
taking documents from her father's desk
or talking to people in the embassy and
conveying information and whatnot to the
Soviets the story becomes very
complicated and she seems to have also
had love affairs with German generals
and with their variety of others in this
and the the Soviets were forever the
Soviet operatives were forever troubled
about what they always felt was the
promiscuity of their American agents
they didn't like it one bit there's a
very puritanical culture and they had
won the one head of a spy ring during
the Second World War
Nathan Gregory Silva master who was
living in a menage tois was another
agent and that deeply troubled them and
in Martha Dodds case they they were fit
to be tied and she went to Moscow she
tried to she wanted to marry this Soviet
fellow in the end he fell victim to the
purchased years and he was executed but
that fact was kept from her for a while
because I hope to continue using her
when she returned to the United States
however she her relationships was the
Roosevelts were not anywhere near as
close once her father had left the
embassy she became a very minor of minor
importance to the Soviet operatives in
the United States and eventually was
more or less cut adrift she fled the
country under congressional subpoena she
and her husband was also a communist
activist fled to the United States in
the 1950s and moved about in a rather
sad almost tragic way from Moscow where
they weren't comfortable to Prague to
Cuba to displace that place and she
never returned she died abroad
she had been by then she'd been indicted
in the United States but but the the
heyday of Martha Dodd and her
involvement with the Soviets was in the
1930s from 1933 to 37 and once again it
brings home another lesson of engaging
this kind of history you're all familiar
with the names Alger Hiss and you're all
familiar with the names of the
Rosenbergs and so forth but and again
just to make a point about the
Rosenbergs because it was a question
that i somebody asked me earlier was
going to ask her if we'd had time I
found we found no evidence that Ethel
Rosenberg was anything more than just a
witting wife who knew what her husband
was doing we found no evidence that she
was actively engaged nor did the Soviets
in certain memos they sent back and
forth find any or a claim that she was
an active agent her husband was but not
her but in the case of Martha Dodd and
the others you're dealing with human
stories you're dealing with with with
stories that often when the climate in
the United States changed became human
tragedies and so one engages in this
kind of research in this kind of history
with whomever whether one considers I'm
guilty of something or innocence of
something one engages respectfully
because they are ultimately human beings
like the rest of us thank you very much
thank you very much I'd like to thank
the accrued status from bookie for
joining us today we still do have a few
comedies of the book go outside and look
at the audience you bring it on a
beautiful spring day sir well I really
appreciate it this